hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara Jessa and tonight I
went and saw Christopher Robin so I grew
up with Pooh and Tigger and ER and kanga
and Roo and rabbit and owl and the
Hundred Acre Woods I loved them growing
up they're very very innocent I guess
it's the word I would use very innocent
and I gotta say I saw the trailer for
this and I felt fear and terror the
design flaw of these beloved characters
is I think it's in the eyes somehow
there are dead little lifeless eyes and
some of them don't have dead lifeless
eyes rabbit and owl are fine but Pooh
and Tigger have lifeless eyes I think
seeing the character design in the
trailer didn't do the movie very much
justice however seeing this film I
really enjoyed myself it was very sweet
very innocent very wholesome just a
feel-good lovely kind movie the movie
really reminded me of saving mr. banks
which is a Disney film from 2013 I
believe and it's one that I don't know
if this is true or not but in my mind it
kind of started these live-action Disney
more serious but still sweet and you
know light Disney films it kind of
started that for me in my minds maybe
I'm wrong but I really loved saving mr.
banks and this had a similar tone it was
very sweet and light-hearted and kind
and honest but there were still some
like sad heavy things but in the end
everything was worked out because
somebody stood up and did the right
thing which is love I'm wearing a crop
top just like poo and I'm ready to talk
about this film so this is the story of
Christopher Robin and all of the
wonderful friends in the Hundred Acre
Wood and Christopher Robin at
some point in his childhood has to leave
and go to boarding school become an
adult's he quickly learns the terrible
ways of the world and then he should
have definitely stayed in the Hundred
Acre Woods where it was safe and lovely
and he had friends no one has friends in
the real world
his father passes away he hates school
he's not allowed to be creative he
though gets out of school and he marries
and he has a child and and he finds a
job and he goes off to war and comes
back a different man and goes to a
terrible job he doesn't love
as a luggage salesman and and is in a
terrible predicament of being a high up
in a luggage salesman job where he has
to downsize the company to save the
companies then you just spend less money
it's also in a time where there's people
of color and women in the workforce for
the first time to the point where the
the head honcho that the very big boss
comes down and he's like trying to
relate to everyone he's like oh I hate
my stuffy office up there and all of its
gold I'm a man's man oh and a woman's I
forget that you're here it's so new it's
it's it's a cute like nod to the time
and so he's got to find a way to save
the budget while also not having the
boss lay off everyone of color and every
every woman in the job force which is
what they're kind of toying at and like
playing him he's also not able to go
hang out with his family it's the time
with his family he's he's not allowed to
hang with his fam you know man what a
bummer
he's not able to spend time with his
family which he desperately wants to do
when they desperately want of him and so
that's the conflict of the film and
that's where everything kind of starts
from during all of this happening you
still get flashes of Winnie the Pooh
standing at the tree that he went
through the last time waiting for
Christopher Robin to come back it's very
sweet the very beginning of the film had
all of the characters from the Hundred
Acre Woods giving a goodbye party to
Christopher Robin before he left off to
boarding school and
my god did it like just it took me back
like in a way that I haven't felt in a
long time it it took me back
so nostalgically to Winnie the Pooh and
and they all were so spot-on with the
characters people it was so sweet gave
Christopher Robin a bag of acorns it's
like this is my very favorite snack
goodness to remember us by it was just
so cute I never like was brought to
tears in the film but the whole time I
felt so welled up with nostalgia and it
was just completely sweet is how I will
describe it I guess there's not a lot of
like uncomfortable or like stressful or
like high-stakes moments the high stakes
don't come from conflicts they come from
just like do the right thing you know
what I mean I loved the cast in this
even McGregor is one of my faves of all
time even in the prequels guys even in
the prequels there were definitely a few
more human characters but it's mostly
just the characters in the Hundred Acre
Wood
I wish their eyes weren't so weird
because they do they're really good
they're pretty they're pretty dead
especially booths and tickers those
they've really got to me I think a lot
of the others worked but for some reason
whose dead eyes will haunt me and that's
a sentence I never thought I'd say
alright so in all of this conflict of
the film who shows up for help because
he's lost all of his friends in the
Hundred Acre Wood and Christopher Robin
sees him in London and he's like it's
stressed because he's so stressed out
from his conflict and he said it's
stress and who was like it's not stress
it's poo it's it's super sweet and super
like lightly cute Oh at this point
though there was a I'm a grown-ass adult
man sitting next to me like seven seats
down and he straight up answers his
phone in the middle of
like a crazy person you don't do that
and then he pretty he spoke to this
person loudly for two minutes to the
point where like three people behind us
like was she get off your phone and oh
my god and I looked at him and finally
built up the courage to give him some
sass I really don't like conflict in
real life so I looked at I was like oh
my god dude you've got to stop talking
and like you've looked at me and like
gave me a stink eye and then close it
he's like I gotta go man close his phone
and was like in a terrible mood for the
rest of the film in a second how have
you gotten this far in life honestly
anyways Christopher Robin goes with food
to help find his friends the rest of the
film it's very sweet Christopher Robin
goes and helps find Pooh helps find
whose friends in the Hundred Acre Woods
and before he leaves
Tigger takes all of his important papers
for his proposal for the budget cuts and
puts in some twigs because Tigger is not
great in this film I always loved Tigger
but I was never like a die-hard Tigger
fan and he didn't win any points for me
in this film I'll say that he or however
was a absolute delight so he leaves he
goes back to London to save everyone's
jobs and he doesn't realize he doesn't
have his papers and the characters
realized that he needs his papers so
they go and try to save him and get him
back his papers and then they meet his
daughter and it turns into more of the
daughter hanging out with them which it
should have been more of I feel like I
should I it should have been more of the
daughter kind of going into the
Christopher Robin role there's a lot
more sign around Christopher Robin I
think now after thinking about it and
watching it then it should have been so
they go when they find Christopher Robin
in this job all in all it all turns out
then at the end the new boss thinks that
that's a great idea and the villain of
the story is portrayed as like this evil
half fell on Pooh gulfs and I think we
all know someone like that just like an
orange
woozle who just golf's a lot and it was
really sweet it was a very like kind of
put together cookie cutter kind of
ending that we all saw coming but it was
still lovely to watch was still really
nice sissy come together I knew it was
gonna come together it was really nice
to see coming together I mean throughout
the film there are two phrases that get
thrown around a lot is that nothing
leads to nothing and then also nothing
leads to the best something and I really
love you know both of those because I do
honestly believe that nothing leads to
nothing but also if you believe hard
enough nothing leads to the best
something it wasn't the best film that
I've seen this year I don't think you
need to see it in the theater if it's
not like your top priority but if you
grew up watching these characters I
think you're really gonna enjoy it
I do still however wish that Pooh had
less menacing eyes you know what I mean
do you know what I'm saying all in all
though I really enjoyed it and I hope
that you do too thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you all next week
Oh bother you
[Music]